mon premier effet ça a été d'envoyer un
message c'est qui il y a les fraîche
et alors c'est pas là c'est pas de la
crème
[Applaudissements]
c'est la troisième fois que vous sortez
avec une copine de votre sœur est-ce que
tu serais pas un ignoble Charo ouais et
est-ce que tu accepterais que un de tes
potes sortent avec ta sœur non
mais en fait
ne devrait pas avoir vis-à-vis de moi je
pense en tout cas moi c'est pas le fait
que ce soit une connaissance à moi qui
sorte avec elle c'est plutôt le fait que
c'est ma petite sœur et que la protéine
et bien sûr ben tu passes avec quelqu'un
qu'elle connaît pas alors que ton pote
tu le connais tu sais qu'il est
justement moi je sais qui c'est mon pote
technique
en fait j'ai pas envie il y a des choses
que j'ai pas envie de savoir donc je
préfère que son amoureux son copain soit
quelqu'un que je ne connais pas c'est
leur solaire les regards plutôt que ce
soit un ami à moi qui qui touche un
minceur j'aurais du mal donc c'est pour
ça que je peux comprendre aussi un peu
son côté mais on n'a pas la même
position son grand frère